les tirs d'artillerie résonne dans le
ciel de personnes en riposte une pluie
de missiles aérien sabato loin les
déflagrations cesse l'espace d'un
instant
lors de cette courte accalmie ce minibus
ukrainien entre en action sa mission
mettre à l'abri les dernières personnes
qui vivent encore ici
ses hommes l'air hagard laisse toute une
vie derrière
de nouveaux bombardements retentissent
une fois en sécurité sept ukrainiens
font tant la
guilde des civils ils bombardent et
tuent des civils ce sont des parasites
ils n'ont pas d'honneur il ne condamne
pas contre des soldats mais contre le
peuple ils sont pires que des fascistes
facile à quelques kilomètres de là
mikolaj ou d'autres ont choisi de rester
malgré les risques dans cet immeuble
alexander a deja frôlé la mort en
sauvant des flammes sa maman dans son
appartement
j'étais là sur le lit un tiers de la
pièce était en feu mon fils et moi
l'avons sorti d'ici on a eu beaucoup de
chance au chocolat chaud pour se
protéger des bombes ces femmes
choisissent de rester dans cet abri
souterrain jour et nuit elle préfère
vivre sous terre plutôt que de quitter
la ville mais on aurait dit nous avons
essayé de créer des conditions de vie
plus ou moins normal ici on se change
les idées ont fait des crêpes on apporte
de la confiture et des boîtes de
conserve et de toute façon nous allons
garder un semblant d'optimisme que
partagent ces quelques ukrainien ils ont
décidé de rester chez eux jusqu'au bout
quel que soit le prix à payer